Good afternoon and welcome colleagues
invited guests,
members of the general public who are
following today's proceedings of the
Standing Senate committee on legal and
constitutional affairs.
Today we continue our consideration of
Bill CC and act to amend the Canadian
Human Rights Act and the criminal code.
And with this,
our last day of hearings on the bill,
we will move to clause by clause
consideration tomorrow with us today for
the first hour or Jordan b Peterson
professors,
psychology department at the University
of Toronto and from the D dot,
Jared Brown Professional Corporation,
a d,
jared brown lead counsel.
Uh,
thank you gentlemen for being here.
You both have up to five minutes for
opening statements.
And Mr Peterson,
I believe you're going to lead off.
Yes sir.
The floor is yours.
So I think the first thing I'd like to
bring up is that it's not obvious when
considering a matter of this sort what
level of analysis is appropriate.
If you're reading any given document,
you can look at the words or the phrases
are the sentences or the complete
document or you can look at the broader
context within which it is likely to be
interpreted and when I first encountered
bill [inaudible] and its surrounding
policies,
it seemed to me that the appropriate
level of analysis was to look at the
context of interpretation surrounding
the bill,
which is what I did when I went and
scoured the Ontario Human Rights
Commission webpages and examine its
policies.
I did that because at that point the
Department of Justice had clearly
indicated on their website in a link
that was later taken down that bill see
16 would be interpreted in within the
precedence policy precedence already
established by the Ontario Human Rights
Commission.
So when I looked on the website,
I thought,
well,
there's broader issues at stake here.
And I tried to outline some of those
broader issues.
In the initial.
You may or may not know.
I made some videos criticizing bill c 16
and it's and a number of.
It's a of the policies that surrounding
it.
And I think the most egregious elements
of the policies are that it requires
compelled speech,
the,
uh,
the Ontario Human Rights Commission
explicitly states that refusing to refer
to a person by their self identified
name and proper personal pronoun,
which is the pronouns that I was
objecting to a can,
the can be interpreted as harassment.
And so that's,
that's explicitly defined in the
relevant policies.
Um,
so I think that's appalling,
first of all because there hasn't been a
piece of legislation that requires
Canadians to utter a particular form of
address that has particular ideological
implications before.
And I think that it's aligned that we
shouldn't cross.
Um,
then I think that the,
the definition of identity that's
enshrined in the surrounding policies is
ill defined and poorly thought through
and also incorrect.
It's incorrect in that identity is not
and will never be something that people
define subjectively because your
identity is something that you actually
have to act out in the world as a set of
procedural tools,
which most people learn.
And I'm being technical about this
between the ages of two and four.
It's a fundamental human reality.
It's well recognized by the relevant
say,
developmental psychological authorities,
and so the idea that identity is
something that you define purely
subjectively is an idea without status
as far as I'm concerned.
I also think it's unbelievably dangerous
for us to move towards a representing a
social constructionist view of identity
in our legal system.
The social constructionist view insists
that human identity is nothing but a
consequence of socialization,
which is which and,
and there's an inordinate amount of
scientific evidence suggesting that that
happens to not be the case.
And so the reason that this is being
instantiated into law is because the
people who are promoting that sort of
perspective,
or at least in part because the people
who are promoting that sort of
perspective know perfectly well that
they've lost the battle completely on
scientific grounds.
It's implicit in the policies of the
Ontario Human Rights Commission that
sexual,
uh,
identity,
a biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression,
um,
sexual proclivity all vary
independently.
And that's simply not the case.
It's not the case scientifically.
It's not the case factually.
And it's certainly not something that
should be increasingly taught to people
in high schools,
elementary schools,
and junior high schools,
which it is,
and it is being taught.
I included this,
a cartoon character that I find
particularly reprehensible,
aimed obviously at it as it is at
children's,
somewhere around the age of seven that
contains within it the implicit can be
implicit claims as a consequence of its
graphic mode of expression that these
elements of identity,
our first canonical and second
independent.
And neither of those happened to be the
case.
I think that the inclusion of gender
expression in the bill is something
extraordinarily peculiar given that
gender expression is not a group.
And that according to the Ontario Human
Rights Commission,
it deals with things as mundane as how
behavior and outward appearance,
such as dress,
hair,
makeup,
body language,
and voice,
which now as far as I can tell,
a open people to charges of hate crime
under bill [inaudible] 16,
if they dare to criticize the manner of
someone's dress,
which seems to me to be an entirely
voluntary issue.
So I think that the Ontario Human Rights
Commission's,
uh,
attitude towards vicarious liability is
designed specifically to be punitive in
that it makes employer's responsible
for,
um,
harassment or discrimination,
including the failure to use a
preferred,
preferred pronouns.
They have vicarious liability for that.
Whether or not they know what's
happening,
whether or not the harassment was and
whether or not the harassment was
intended or unintended.
So all stopped with that.
Thank you.
Mr Brown.
I'm a litigator in Toronto,
act and all manner of commercial and
employment disputes.
I'm not an academic.
I live with my clients in the land
illegal reality and how the law actually
works.
About two years ago,
I began to see claims of discrimination
included in every employment related ct
claim.
My phone now rings weekly with human
rights.
Tribunal matters.
It has become a reality for employers
across Canada.
In August of last year,
I became aware of Dr Jordan Pearson.
He was discussing
what he saw as a problematic law,
poorly written.
That's when I observed the oddest thing
happening.
Lawyers,
academic lawyers,
important people began to say that he
had the legal stuff wrong.
Nothing unusual about this bill,
and they also said,
you don't get to go to jail if you
breach a human rights tribunal order.
What was happening is they weren't
defending the law but downplaying its
effects.
Now,
as a practicing lawyer,
anytime a lawyer and particularly an
academic says,
look away,
there's nothing to see here.
It gets my antenna way up.
So I did some research which can be
found in the brief that I filed in
advance of today.
It sets out the path,
the prison on this I knew as a
commercial litigator that anyone can end
up in jail if you breach a tribunal
order.
It is a simple civil contempt of court
process.
People go to jail for this,
but what about the freedom of expression
issue?
It's a foundational issue.
We all know that section two,
b of the charter sets out that everybody
has the fundamental freedoms of thought,
belief,
opinion and expression,
and we all know that the government is
successfully restricted freedom of
expression over the years.
But what if rather than restricting what
you can say,
the government actually mandated what
you must say.
In other words,
instead of legislating that you cannot
defame someone.
For instance,
the government says,
when you speak about a particular
subject,
let's say gender,
you must use this government approved
set of words and theories.
The American jurisprudence clearly
defines this is unconstitutional
compelled speech in Canada.
The Supreme Court has annunciated the
principle that anything that forces
someone to express opinions that are not
their own is a penalty.
That is to Talbot's Herrion and as such,
alien to the tradition of free nations
like Canada.
Now to see [inaudible] get us to
compelled speech,
the Minister of Justice is summarized.
Bill see 16 as the enactment amends the
Canadian Human Rights Act to that gender
identity and gender expression to the
list of prohibited grounds of
discrimination.
The Department of Justice website used
to say that we must look to the Ontario
Human Rights Commission policies for
definitions on these terms.
Ontario's policies on gender identity
and gender expression are so my brief.
They state that gender based harassment
can involve refusing to refer to a
person by their self identified name and
proper personal pronoun,
refusing to refer to a trans person by
their chosen name,
and a personal pronoun that matches
their gender identity will likely be
discrimination.
The law's otherwise unsettled as to
whether someone can insist on any one
gender neutral pronoun in particularly
if the Harasser didn't know or didn't
intend to harass.
It's still harassment.
Now,
why is this important?
Well,
in Ontario Human Rights Commission as a
policy development creature of the
legislature,
it creates the policies which interpret
the code,
but what is most important,
the tribunal must follow these policies.
It is bound by them so the commission
creates the law on pronouns and Ontario.
The policies on pronouns were introduced
into the legal framework after the law
had left the legislature federally,
the same process will be followed as the
Department of Justice had said so a
similar guideline will be developed as
with the Ontario policies.
Federal guidelines must be followed by
the federal tribunal.
The guidelines will mandate pronouns.
This will happen after the bill leaves
the Senate,
mandating use of pronouns requires one
to use words that are not their own,
which imply a belief in or an agreement
with a certain theory on gender.
If you try to disavow that theory,
you can be brought before the human
rights commission for Ms Dot gendering
or potentially find yourself guilty of a
hate crime.
To sum up on the subject of gender,
we're going to have government mandated
speech now in a on the constitutionality
of the proposed bill,
the Department of Justice said on its
website,
look,
there's a variation of this bill that
already exists in most of the provinces.
I don't believe that's a robust argument
in favor of constitutionality.
I would refer you to the comments of the
now Chief Justice Mclaughlin of the
Supreme Court and the decision to
Taylor.
It's in my brief.
The chilling effect of leaving overbroad
provisions on the books cannot be
ignored.
While the chilling effect of human
rights legislation is likely to be less
significant than that of a criminal
prohibition,
the vagueness of the law means it may
well determine more conduct than can
legitimately be targeted as a lawyer on
the ground,
I worry about poorly drafted a poorly
drafted law and its impact on my
clients.
As a Canadian,
I worry about parliament tacitly
authorizing compelled speech.
The brief I provided to the committee
contains a comprehensive legal opinion
that I published back in December on
[inaudible].
There's a table that shows how the
federal human rights regime mirrors the
Ontario system in terms of enforcement
of policies and guidance or wrap up sir.
And finally,
it includes the case law that underpins
the opinion.
Thank you.
Thank you both.
And we'll begin the questions beginning
with a different.
Sure.
So Baker.
Thank you.
Thank you Mr. Chairman and thank you to
the witnesses for their presentation.
As the witnesses know,
the nine provinces in Canada,
uh,
have,
the,
um,
the provision in their laws including
Ontario and also the words expression,
as I recall appears in four or five
provinces.
Um,
so what you are arguing is against what
we already have in law,
your reference to the criminality to,
to the sections of the criminal code at
our last meeting,
senators wow correctly pointed out that
sections three,
18 and slash 19
starts off by genocide
under the heading genocide.
The next heading is a public incitement
likely to lead to a breach of the peace.
And you know,
what a breach of the peace is,
Mr Brown,
willful promotion of hatred.
These things are.
And then there are defenses listed as
you know,
in that criminal code provision,
there are several defense,
if you honestly believe in what you said
is if,
if you,
you know,
the,
the defenses are extensive in the
criminal code,
they've worked well for Canada.
So
what do you have to say about the facts
of what's presently in the criminal code
and your reflection that somehow,
uh,
the genocide heading,
the heading on public incitement on
willful promotion of hatred somehow that
these provisions should not be included
under those headings?
I think I have to be clear,
my presentation relates to the
amendments of the human rights code or
the Criminal Code,
and that is in fact how a one like Dr
Peterson may in fact find themselves on
the wrong side of jail.
And so if you have,
if you've reviewed the,
uh,
the publication in the opinion,
I say that a simply by breaching the,
a proposed amendment to the,
uh,
to the human rights act,
um,
and particularly with somebody who is
deliberately doing so for instance,
somebody was saying,
I'm not going to use those words,
that person,
if they are dragged before the tribunal,
the Ontario Tribune or the federal
tribunal,
I've indicated to you already that the
Department of Justice has said they're
going to pass the same guideline on
pronouns.
And so what I'm suggesting to you is
that if somebody says,
I'm not going to use those words are
brought before the tribunal,
the Federal Tribunal and the tribunal
then delivers an order for payment of a
fine.
And alternatively a nonmonetary remedy.
I,
he cease and desist order,
uh,
an order to do something,
to compel them to do something.
And that person who's brought before the
tribunal says,
I'm not doing that.
They will find themselves in contempt of
court and prison is the likely outcome
of that process until they purge the
content.
That's what I'm suggesting.
I'm not suggesting to you that,
uh,
that the,
amendments to the criminal code,
um,
well I'm,
I'm not advocating genocide.
I guess let's just say that.
And My,
my presentation here is,
is restricted to what I see as the
Pronoun policy issue in the compelled
speech issue.
So it covers the provincial legislation
if you distraught to disagree with that
we've had in place in the provinces for
decades in some cases,
is the policies that were enacted after
it left the legislature and which will
be enacted after this bill leaves this,
the,
this committee.
I would also like to add to that the
fact that once I made the video stating
that I wouldn't use the Z and Zer
pronouns,
for example,
which I regard as part of the
ideological linguistic vanguard,
the university lawyers after carefully
considering what I said,
sent me two letters to cease and desist
in my public utterances because they
believed that not only was I violating
the university standards of conduct,
but then I was also violating the
relevant provisions of the Ontario Human
Rights Commission.
Therefore,
as far as I could tell,
vindicating the statement that I made
when I made the video to begin with,
which was that the act of making the
video itself was probably already
illegal and they didn't do that lightly
on the provincial.
Yes.
Senator to put.
Thank you.
Chair and thank you gentlemen.
Both of you for being here.
Um,
two questions.
One for Dr Peterson at the get go.
And then one for the two of you.
Hopefully the chair will indulge me a
deliberations of this bill.
And during deliberations of this bill,
we keep hearing the term respect,
throwing around respect as indeed
critical in debates of legislation as
sensitive as this.
And there are a lot of people here who
need to be reminded that respect works
both ways,
including people at this committee.
Uh,
Dr Baker,
Senator Baker has already referred to
comments as genocide.
I don't think anybody here is promoting
genocide.
However,
Dr. Peterson,
can you comment on the notion of respect
where some of your critics say,
why can you not just respect your
students,
just use the gender neutral pronouns?
How do you respond to that?
Well,
first of all,
I'd have to be convinced that doing so
would do more good than harm.
And I don't believe that and I think I'm
actually in a reasonable position to,
to,
to justify my claim.
I think that the danger that's intrinsic
to the law far outweighs whatever
potential benefit it might produce.
Especially given that there's no hard
evidence whatsoever for any.
I would also like to point out that the
people who are promoting this
legislation claim to be acting on the
behalf behalf say of the transgender
community,
but they weren't not elected nor
appointed to act as such representatives
and they're doing it on their own.
Say.
So.
I've received many letters,
at least 30 now from transgendered
individuals indicating that the,
they are not in accordance with the
claims of these so called
representatives to be representing or
with the intent of the legislation,
which has actually made them more
visible rather than less visible,
which is.
And the less visible is what they had
preferred with regards to respect is
that you don't meet people generally
speaking in a mutual display of respect.
You generally meet people in a mutual
display of alert neutrality,
which is the appropriate way to begin an
interaction with someone because respect
is something that you earn as a
consequence of reciprocal interactions
with wwe that are dependent on something
like reputation,
which is also a consequence of repeated
interactions.
And so the notion that addressing
someone by their,
um,
self-defined self identity isn't
necessarily an indication of basic human
respect for them,
I think is entirely spurious argument,
especially given that there's no
evidence that moving the language in a
compelling manner in this direction is
going to have any beneficial effect.
We're supposed to assume that just
because hypothetically the intent is
positive,
that the outcome will be positive and
any social scientist worth his or her
salt knows perfectly well that that's
rarely the case.
So
Dr Brown,
uh,
you've talked about a nonmonetary
orders,
uh,
that could include sanctions like orders
to undertake sensitivity and anti bias
training.
I would like a,
either one or both of you to comment on
whether you could explain why an
individual may have a strong objection
to undertaking such a training.
And Mr Brown,
could you let the committee know how
serious the sanction could be?
An of course you already dead on that.
Uh,
if you refuse to undertake such an
order,
uh,
and specifically at the federal level,
but what would,
what would,
why would people have an objection to
taking such training?
I think I'm going to let Dr Peterson
answer why he or someone like him might
have an objection to undertaking that
type of training.
Obviously,
once again with the severity of that
decision.
If it gets before the tribunal,
well,
I have a profound objection to,
to undergoing such training.
In fact,
I would flatly refuse under all
conditions to undergo it.
And the reason,
there's multiple reasons for that.
The first reason is that the science
surrounding the,
uh,
the so called charge of implicit bias
that's associated with perception is by
no means settled in,
in to such a degree that to one of the
three people who designed the most
commonly used measure,
which is the implicit association test,
has detached himself from the other two
researchers on the grounds that the use
of the test has become,
has far its scientific validity and
reliability.
It's nowhere near valid or reliable
enough to be used in the manner that
it's been using.
And even the more a pro iat researchers
who developed the test have admitted to
that publicly,
even though they haven't stressed it
nearly to the degree they showed up.
So first of all,
the sciences is not settled and is being
used absolutely inappropriately and I
can say that as a clinician because I
know that and as a psychometrician I
know the criteria for using a test for a
six essentially diagnostic purposes and
the iat doesn't even come close to
what's necessary.
Then the next issue is,
well,
where's the evidence that an anti
unconscious bias training works?
There's no evidence and what little
evidence there is suggests that it
actually has the opposite effect because
people don't like being brought in front
of a reeducation committee and having
their fundamental perceptions.
You see their perceptions,
not even their thoughts,
but their perceptions themselves altered
by collective Fiat.
It's an unbelievable honor sir.
We have a very engaged committee,
concise questions and concise responses
with the helpful,
uh,
senator prep.
Thank you for being here.
I want to briefly for the documents from
the Ontario Human Rights Commission says
some people may not know how to
determine what Pronoun to use.
Others may feel uncomfortable using
gender neutral pronouns.
Generally.
When in doubt,
ask a person how they wish to be
addressed Tuesday.
If you don't know which Pronoun to use,
his preferred,
simply referring to their person by
their chosen name is always a respectful
approach.
So you can use the pronoun,
you can choose,
you can use their chosen name.
So if someone chooses to change his name
from Paul to Peter,
surely you'd use Peter because it's a
matter of simple politeness and respect.
If that same person is the person
chooses to cheat,
to change our name from Paul to Paula,
won't.
I won't use you.
Use the name Polo simply as a matter of
respect.
What's the difference here?
Well,
I guess the issue with that and the
speaker about the legal issue there is
that you're now introducing the full
force of the law behind the requirement
to use.
And I'm dealing obviously with,
with respect to the pronoun issue in
terms of not addressing somebody by
their,
by their legally registered name,
for instance.
Um,
uh,
I don't think that's where we're running
into trouble here.
I think the issue becomes that if you
don't address somebody by the,
uh,
the pronoun that they self identify by
as I've read out to you the fact that
the full force of the law will be behind
a that person.
I'm that that's what I,
I'm a finding as trump,
troubling in the legislation,
but the Ontario Human Rights Commission
gives people the alternative not to use
pronouns and use the person's chosen
name it,
which is always a respectful approach.
So pronouns are not necessary or not
mandatory.
You can always choose the person's
chosen name as a respectful approach.
And therefore,
I'm not aware that anybody,
that there is a,
um,
a piece of legislation that compels you
to use my proper name.
In other words,
once again,
it's the fact that the full force of the
law will be behind it when we're dealing
with the group being identified in the
legislation.
And so,
for instance,
I were not to call you by your chosen
name.
I'm not sure you'd enjoy the full force
of law behind you.
Uh,
um,
as a result of that.
And that's what I'm suggesting to you is
the difference here.
I'm just sorry.
When you said that you always base
whatever you say on what the Ontario
Human Rights Commission is saying,
and I'm quoting from the Ontario Human
Rights Commission document.
They're saying we're not mandated
mandating pronouns.
You can always use the person's chosen
name as a respectful approach.
I respectfully disagree,
but then,
well I would say then that's actually an
indication of just exactly how important
the policy documents are written because
I can quote this one which which is also
from the Ontario Human Rights Commission
website that says,
and I quote,
refusing,
refusing to refer to a person by their
self identified name and proper
personal,
proper personal pronouns.
Counts constitutes gender based
harassment.
And so if there.
If the policies are written in a
coherent manner and there wasn't
internal contradictions,
then your statement would be a
reasonable objection.
But since it's not written that way,
and I do believe firmly that that's a
testament to the.
To the degree to which it's supporting
written set of policies,
is it?
It's full of internal contradictions and
that'll be worked out very painfully
within the confines of people's private
lives.
Thank you sir.
Good.
Well,
senator batters.
Thanks very much.
Both of you for being here.
First of all,
Dr Peterson.
I want to go back to this issue of
personal pronouns and if you could
please tell our committee more about
this issue.
It's something that I was not at all
familiar with prior to this bill
being introduced and in particular about
the gender neutral pronouns and your
experience in pushing back against being
forced to use those general neutral
gender neutral pronouns.
Well,
I don't think the people who initiated
this legislation ever expected that
there would be an absolute explosion of
of identities,
first of all,
and also so-called personal pronouns as
there has been.
I think facebook now recognize as
something like 71 separate gender
identity categories,
each of which in principle is associated
with its own set of pronouns and so it's
become what linguistically and it's.
It's become a parody essentially.
It's become linguistically unmanageable
and it's also the case that words can't
be introduced into the language by Fiat.
I don't.
I can't even think of a time when that's
actually work.
We're not exactly sure how words enter
the common parlance,
but it's certainly not that way.
And so the,
the,
the legislation devolves into a kind of,
of,
of the absurdity as far as I can tell.
I mean,
one of the people that I discussed this
with claim that the way that you kept
track of someone's personal pronouns was
to use your cell phone as an adjunct to
your communication.
And I mean that's,
you wouldn't say anything like that if
you knew anything about
common human nature,
let's say in the matter in which people
communicate with one another.
So
the types of pronouns are talking about
just so everyone's clear,
because I don't think these are common
common parlance,
um,
ze Zer and what other sorts of gender
neutral pronouns are we discussing?
Well,
I have very bad memory for that sort of
thing,
but if you're interested in that,
you can find lists of them very rapidly
on the web and they'd been produced by,
I think they'd been produced by people
whose essential desire is to gain
linguistic control.
That's,
that's,
that's as simple as I can put it is to
gain linguistic control,
but they're not used popularly and,
and that seems to me to be a real
problem as a consequence that you make
failure to make their use something that
could carry a criminal penalty.
So I just don't understand that and,
and I don't understand how the
government can justify imposing a
criminal penalty on the use of words
that no one either knows or uses it.
It just seems preposterous to me.
But there it is.
Could you please also tell us a little
bit more about the,
your personal experience in pushing back
against this?
And I mean many are familiar with your
story but not everyone.
So I just want to give you a little.
Well,
I made a video,
actually made three videos,
but we'll just talk about one of them.
I thought I made one criticizing bill c
16 for the reasons that I already
described because I went and read the
policies and I made my hair stand on end
to the surrounding policies.
And,
uh,
so I made a video stating essentially
that and detailed out my reasons and um,
you know,
I've been following the battle of let's
say,
ideologies on campus for a very long
period of time and I suppose I have some
expertise in that and there's a,
there's an ideological war that's
ripping a campuses apart and it's
essentially between a,
an ideological variant that's rooted in
what's come to be known as postmodernism
with kind of the Neo Marxist base and,
and modern modernism.
I would say that that's accounting for
all the turmoil on campuses.
And I see this as an extension of this
campus turmoil into the broader world.
And,
and I really believe that is the proper
level of analysis.
I truly believe that.
And so I said that I believe that this
is the V,
a vanguard issue in a kind of
ideological war and that I'm not going
to participate on the side of the people
whose,
whose ideological stance I find
reprehensible,
unforgivable and reprehensible,
especially the Marxist element of it.
And so I announced that I was going to
use these words because I don't believe
that they're instantiating to protect
anyone's rights.
I believe they're,
that the,
the,
the ideologues who are pushing this
movement are using unsuspecting and
sometimes complicit members of the so
called transgender community to push
their ideological vanguard forward.
And I firmly believe that so I'm not
participating in that.
And the fact that it's potentially
illegal for me not to participate in
that is something that I regard as.
I think that's absolutely dreadful.
It's,
it makes,
it puts a shutter in my heart as a
Canadian that we could even possibly be
in a situation like that.
You know,
if,
if the,
if the identity claims that are
instantiated in this lead,
in the policies surrounding this
legislation are applied,
it's going to be held for the
psychiatrist,
excuse my language.
It's going to be very difficult for the
biologists and the psychiatrists next.
And I think we'll see that happening
very soon.
Thank you,
Senator Gold.
Thank you.
And thank you for being here.
Um,
uh,
I,
I'm never been a practicing lawyer.
I was a constitutional law professor and
I'm a free speech guy.
Um,
so I appreciate the importance of the
issues that are being raised.
I think respectfully they were answered
free speech issues were answered quite
compellingly by my former colleague,
Brenda Cosmin and testimony before this
committee.
But I,
I wanted to make three points,
um,
uh,
Mr Peterson and there are questions sort
of varied in this point.
I think I heard you say that you thought
that the harm to this legislation
outweighs the good but,
but,
but there is the trans community suffers
harm regularly when they're
discriminated against and whatever else.
One might say and worry about human
rights tribunals and the like.
This bill addresses and would take a
major step forward towards reducing
harm,
uh,
that are particularly vulnerable
community experiences.
Second,
let's see if we could zero in on where
we might agree that
there is nothing in the law that
criminalizes or creates a,
an offense to criticize the notion that
identity as a social construct,
which you do to criticize the way in
which words come into the language.
The Modern Hebrews and example of where
it's coming in by fee and the academy
says,
does it as well for Shakespeare gave us
so much of our language,
but there's nothing in this bill that
stands in the way of you taking a
principal position against all aspects
of this including your criticisms of the
activist.
And the issue is the Pronoun.
And,
and unless I'm reading it wrong,
uh,
Senator Pratte pointed out the Ontario
Human Rights Commission policy does not
say that refusing to use a person's self
identified name or personal pronoun does
Constitute Gender based harassment.
I May,
I may be wrong,
but I believe it said it could and I
think that's a real difference.
If,
if I turn to you and say,
look,
please call me they because how I see
myself now,
because it's hurtful for you to call me
sir,
or miss whatever,
whatever it would be a.
But you refuse.
And I say,
well,
Kate,
if you're uncomfortable with that
because you're not comfortable with
that,
call me mark,
and you refuse to continue to call me by
the name that I'm telling you is perfect
to me.
Is that not in fact,
something that,
is that not something that the law can
properly address?
This is you were knowingly hurting me.
Uh,
and,
and in that respect,
our courts ultimately,
I think are capable of striking a proper
balance between people who slip up or
who,
for whatever reasons,
just can't get the words out of their
mouth and those that persist and
intentionally causing it to respond.
Would you agree with my characterization
of the,
uh,
free speech as it applies to these
issues?
Let me jump in.
Just on the legal point,
after Dr Peterson posted these videos
and after he ruins to the consciousness,
the Ontario human rights commission
deemed fit to release a new policy
document called questions and answers
about gender identity and pronouns.
And in so doing,
they said that refusing to refer to a
trans person by their chosen name and pr
and a personal pronoun that matches
their gender identity or purposely
misgendering will likely be
discrimination.
So I think it's a little bit more
certain than what you may have a
indicated in your comments,
but I'll love Dr. um,
a and once again that was,
that policy was,
was put out after Dr Peterson began to
speak on the issue and so I think that's
very telling that it was a,
a response if you will,
to this,
this,
um,
this issue that Dr Peterson raised.
I going to know obviously Dr Pearson to
go ahead with the other element of your
question very briefly sir.
Well,
so I would say that the very idea that
calling someone a term that they didn't
choose causes them such irreparable harm
that legal remedies should be sought.
Um,
rather than regarding it as a form of
impoliteness that legal remedies should,
should be sought,
including potential violation of the
hate speech codes is an indication of
just how deeply the culture of
victimization is sunk into our society.
Okay.
We'll leave it.
There are a senator from
same topic with Mr Brown at when the
Minister of Justice was before this
committee.
She said the following,
there is nothing within bill [inaudible]
that would compel somebody to have to
call somebody by the pronouns he or she
or otherwise can you comment on
preposition?
But I'd
agree with that.
There is nothing in the bill,
but the problem is that in the,
uh,
the government of Canada,
Department of Justice website,
um,
they,
uh,
in their questions and answer section of
their website which was pulled down in
December,
it's that top five of my brief.
It makes very clear that the definitions
of the terms gender identity and gender
expression have already been given by
the Ontario Human Rights Commission.
The commission has provided helpful
discussion and examples that can offer
good practical guidance.
The Canadian Human Rights Commission
will provide similar guidance on the
meaning of these terms in the Canadian
Human Rights Act.
Now I take that to the legislative
intent and I'll agree with you that the,
that the bill itself on its face does
not seem to imply any manner of
compelled speech.
But when we're tying it so deliberately
and with this expectation,
that's where I think you get into a,
into some trouble.
Mr Barney,
he spoke about the chilling effects of
overly broad accusation.
I'm wondering if you consider the terms
gender identity and gender expression to
be equally,
or do you consider one broader than the,
um,
I think they are overly broad
definitions and,
uh,
and I think the only thing I can offer
as a lawyer and a litigator is that,
um,
the courts don't like overbroad terms
and I,
and I would refer you to the decision of
a London boy Berto Court of Appeal,
where in that case the court of appeals
is the objective of statutory
interpretation is,
does,
is to discern the legislative intent
from the language of the legislation if
possible.
And to give effect to such intent.
This objective becomes difficult to
attain.
Where there is conflict in precision or
a lack of clarity in the legislation of
particularly of particular concern in
the area of human rights law is that a
lack of clarity will cast a chill on the
exercise on the,
of the fundamental freedoms such as
freedom of expression and religion.
And so,
um,
while I personally believe that the,
that the terms are not properly or not
clearly defined and,
and somewhat ambiguous,
the courts don't like that type of
legislation either,
just to add two things.
Um,
with regards to the chill,
it's already the case and I've seen this
among my own students when they're
teaching personality,
which is what I teach,
which also involves a assessment of
gender differences between men and women
that the proclivity now is for the
advanced phd students to avoid any such
discussions in their classrooms because
of the potential cost of transgressing
against,
uh,
an unknown norm,
let's say is so high that it's just
easier to teach other things.
And so I've seen that clearly and with
multiple people.
And I would also say that it's no
trivial matter that the department of
Justice's link to the Ontario Human
Rights Commission and their statements
about how this legislation was going to
be interpreted mysteriously disappeared
in the middle of December.
Of all the things that have happened to
me happened in relationship to this ad
that I'd been studying.
I think that was the most chilling.
So because it was the,
it was the,
what would you say it was the smoking
pistol,
right?
Because the issue is what's the right
level of analysis?
He just supposed to look at the
legislation.
Well,
since the Justice Department said no,
you're supposed to look at the
surrounding policies.
Well that's what I did and that's what I
based my case on.
And then all of a sudden the link to
those,
the link tying those two things together
just vanished and people had to go into
the Internet archives to,
to,
to fish it back out so that it could
remain part of the public record.
I think that's absolutely scandalous.
Thank you.
Senator.
I'm adver.
Thank you chair.
And thank you both of you for being
here.
Um,
I was trying to take notes,
but I think I got this right of Peterson
that you talked about this bill as being
an expression of vanguard of ideology.
Am My,
am I right in thinking in,
in?
Well,
I was thinking more about the policies
that surrounded it but,
but yes.
Yeah.
So I'm trying to.
Where would you as a party of one are
saying that published documents from the
Canadian psychological association,
the American Psychological Association,
the Canadian Medical Association,
the American Psychiatric Association,
the Canadian Psychiatry Association,
and the United Nation human rights
experts.
So these are all,
you know,
these are no parties at one associated.
They are all,
I imagine,
lots of psychologists and members of the
Canadian Psychology Association and the
Canadian Psychiatry.
So how would you describe what you're
saying,
which is your opinion,
which you are absolutely entitled to
with what everyone is saying,
plus the feelings and testimonies of the
people who have suffered over 30 years.
We've been taking issues to court.
These are people who will.
We listened to.
So how would we describe that?
Okay.
Well,
with regards to your second point,
if the people that you're listening to
are randomly selected from a population,
then their opinions are worthless from
the perspective of,
of testimony because you don't know if
you're dealing with a biased sample.
And that's a big problem with the public
consultation process that underlies this
bill and you can not appreciate that if
you'd like,
but it's standard practice in any,
in any polling institution or any body
that's attempting to extract the genuine
opinion out of a so called community of
people.
And if that isn't followed then you
can't tell if the information that
you're receiving is bias.
And this with regards to your first
point,
what exactly are all those people who
aren't thinking the same way as me sake.
You said that there's a bunch of them
and a bunch of groups,
but you never said what they're saying
precisely.
Well,
I think our chair who drew me out to 45
percent of your fund to vet out what
they're all saying,
but in general they say they oppose
discrimination and harassment because of
gender identity and gender expression
and then there's three pages.
I can show it.
I oppose discrimination against gender
identity and gender expression.
That's not the point.
The point is the specifics of the
legislation that's around it and the
insistence that people will have to be a
half to use compelled speech.
That's what I'm objecting to.
I've dealt with all sorts of people in
my life,
very people who don't fit in and now all
sorts of different ways.
I'm not a discriminatory person.
There's 500 hours of my teaching to my
classrooms on tape,
on Youtube,
but nobody's found a smoking pistol.
I'm not a discriminatory individually,
but I think this legislation is
reprehensible and I do not believe for a
moment that it will do what it intends
to do.
I also don't think that my opinion
deviates substantially from the bodies
that you're describing because you
haven't provided any evidence that they
say anything other than discrimination
is a bad thing and I think that
unreasonable discrimination is a bad
thing and it's unreasonable.
When people are judged for any reason
other than the specific competence that
they bring to say a given physician.
It's not in anyone's best interest that
that occurs,
but I don't think that you've
demonstrated in the least that the
opinions that I'm putting forward are
exist in opposition to the standard
practices of a say of my particular
discipline.
So could you.
Could you repeat one more time?
Your response to Senate says Golden
Pratt,
that the Ontario human rights commission
has provided what I would say reasonable
alternatives to your.
Your objection to using pronouns?
Well,
I think it's been made clear in the,
in the presentation so far is that it
depends on which part of the Ontario
Human Rights Commission's policies you
read.
And that's a big problem.
I mean that's one of the reasons I
criticized this to begin with was
because when I went through the
policies,
I could see that you're absolutely
incoherent.
So for example,
here,
let me give you another example.
So there's an insistence in the Ontario
Human Rights Commission that sexual
preferences and immutable phenomena,
which indicates at least in principle
that it's biologically grounded,
but on the same,
by the same token,
in exactly the same policies,
they presume that sexual identity,
gender identity and gender expression
are entirely independent.
It's like,
sorry guys,
you can't have both of those because
one's a and one's not a and you can't
put those together and like there's.
There's endless numbers of places in the
policy surround surrounding bill c 16
that are characterized by that kind of
logical incoherency I mean what you're
going to do to people who are
transgender who are making the claim
that they were saved born that way at
birth,
which is a strong claim.
That's a biological claim.
It indicates that there's a direct
causal connection between some
biological phenomena and the expression
of a particular identity.
It's actually the strongest defense that
people who have,
let's call them nonstandard sexual
identities or gender identities,
have to defend the claim.
So I have to wrap it up there and move
on to a senator well avenue Mr at.
Thank you
very much.
Mr Chair,
I'll leave the time for our guests to
put in their translation devices.
Thank you very much for being here.
My question is for Mr Peterson,
do you have the interpretation now,
sir,
so
I'm still trying to orient myself a
little bit in this bill.
I'm a little bit lost in the arguments
for and against,
but some arguments really struck me
because some people said that without
this bill
there might be suicides.
People would become depressed.
Okay.
Transgender people of course,
and
it seems to me that this is almost an
extreme position that without this bill
there would be an explosion of suicides
and depression.
So I'd like to ask you a question.
As a professor now you work in the,
the,
the social sciences,
you study human behavior.
Are there studies or statistics
about the consequences that this bill
would have on those people?
Is this bill,
would this bill save as many lives and
help as many people as it says?
Well,
in,
in principle,
we would have that information if the
policies that have already been
introduced by the provincial governments
were assessed properly,
but as far as I know,
there's been no known studies indicating
that the introduction of this
legislation specifically has done
anything to modify the,
the unfortunate rates of suicide,
depression,
anxiety and so forth that are bitter
characteristic.
Well,
you could say often of marginalized
groups,
but that's a bit of an overstatement.
So no,
I don't that,
that,
that was part of my original claim is
that there's no evidence that this sort
of,
um,
legal redress,
let's say is going to produce any of the
positive consequences that are intended.
And I do believe that by making the
issue,
let's say painfully visible,
that's one way of thinking about it.
There's actually had the opposite effect
and it's,
you know,
it's,
it's very,
very common and this is something
that's,
that's well known in,
in the relevant social sciences that
just because you intend something to
happen when you make a large scale
transformation doesn't indicate in any
manner that that's going to be the
outcome.
I mean,
it would be lovely if things were that
simple and I mean the best social
scientists always insist that you build
an outcome analysis into any,
into any broad scale,
what would you call a social
intervention because there's a good
chance it'll backfire,
there's a high chance it'll backfire,
so it's all presupposition and it's
based at least in part on the notion
that the transgender community is a
community and that there are voices that
speak for them homogenously and that
this is what they all want and that will
work as intended.
And to me looking at this from,
from the social science perspective,
it's,
there's nothing about it that's
credible.
Missy and I also don't buy the intent,
so good.
Senator Dupuis.
See Ms Dot.
Thank you,
Mr Chairman.
Okay.
First of all,
I'd like to ask a question to Mr
Peterson and perhaps I would also have a
question for Mr Brown.
My question is as follows,
Dr Peterson.
I'm trying to understand your position.
Okay.
Do you see a difference
between the opinions that you expressed
that you were expressing today on this
issue
as part of this public consultation?
Okay,
and the actions that you take as a
university professor where you are in a
position of authority and power over
your students?
Well,
first of all,
I don't necessarily consider myself in a
position of authority and power.
I consider myself in a position of
responsibility.
Those aren't the same thing,
so I don't agree with the way that the
question is formulated and I don't
understand what that has to do with my
stance.
I mean if I believe that the legislation
is going to do more harm than good and I
also firmly believe which I do,
that it is more in the issue of
ideological move than,
than,
than something that's designed to
address the concerns that it purports to
address.
I would also like to point out briefly
that you know,
what should have happened when I made
that video and this is relevant to the
question,
was that like maybe people paid
attention to 10 minutes to do to it for
10 minutes and maybe he'd got a
newspaper article and then it
disappeared.
But I put my finger on something.
That's what I thought.
And the fact that this issue hasn't gone
away in nine months,
quite the contrary,
it's exploded not only in Canada but in
all sorts of parts of the world means
that I means to me that I have some
evidence that my choice of level of
analysis was correct and that there's
far more going on here,
so to speak.
Then the mirror surface issue that we're
purporting to discuss and so I take
exception to the notion that I'm somehow
abandoning my personal responsibility to
my students,
which is something that I believe is in
fact driving what I'm doing.
I believe that my obligation to my
students constantly used to tell them
what I think and to make that as
informed and careful and opinion as I
can possibly matter.
Map Master.
And that's what I do.
Zip asked him component.
You can see.
I think that you understand that if you
come to participate or to appear a
Senate committee studying a bill,
regardless of what we think of the
question
that.
I mean,
my question for you is,
do you make a difference between your
opinion,
what you say and the fact that the
university which pays you,
I believe unless I'm wrong,
the university considers you to be under
its legal responsibility and so you are
in a situation of authority over your
students and this means that you can
give an,
a or an f to your students
components of the legislation.
That's rolling.
I'm going to move on.
Senator Mcdonald,
you can care
for you.
Um,
the thing that concerns me most in this
legislation is compelled speech.
And I think that's very concerning.
Um,
this committee is hearing from Megan
Murphy who told us her opposition to
this concept of gender fluidity,
fluidity because you believe gender is a
social construction.
And Dr Gad Saad also posed for this
legislation because of his belief in
evolutionary biology.
What this shows is that with bill
[inaudible] and we are prematurely
shutting down a discussion on gender and
sex as far from settler appears to be
fair,
settled.
Uh,
and in my opinion,
when we looked at the provincial
definition is set up by the commissions.
We are enshrining the theory of a gender
spectrum into the law.
I'm one of you can comment on
that's exactly what we're doing.
We're in and I think I think that that
might even be more dangerous than in my
opinion,
than the compelled speech issue because
the social constructionist view of
gender isn't another opinion.
It's just wrong.
So because I can.
I can tell you why that is fairly.
I'll take one minute to do that.
Well,
the proposition that's instantiated,
for example in this particular visual,
which is a good representation of the of
the philosophy of the policies,
is that there is no causal relationship
between these four dimensions of
identity and that's palpably observed.
I mean 98 percent of people.
It's 99 point seven percent of people
who inhabit a body with a given
biological sex identify it with that
biological sex.
It's.
It's incredibly tightly linked.
If you can't
attribute causality to a link that
that's tight,
that's tight.
You have to dispense with the notion of
causality altogether and then of the
people who who identify as say,
as male or female who were also
biologically male or female.
The vast majority of them have this
sexual preference that would go along
with that and the gender identity and
gender expression.
These,
these levels of analysis are
unbelievably tightly linked and the,
the evidence that biological factors
play a role in determining gender
identity is in a word overwhelming.
There isn't a serious scientist alive
who would dispute that now you get,
you get disputes about it,
but they always stem from essentially
from the humanities.
And as far as I'm concerned,
I've looked at it very carefully.
Those arguments are entirely
ideologically driven.
It's a tenant of the ideology that
identity is socially constructed.
And that's partly why it's been
instantiated into law because there's no
way they're going to win the argument,
but they can certainly win,
let's say the propaganda war,
especially by foisting,
this sort of reprehensible,
uh,
advertising information on children.
And that's part of the,
that's part of the express intent.
I would add.
A trans complainants have been covered
under the existing grounds of sex before
the tribunals across Canada.
And as the Minister of Justice said,
they are bringing this legislation in as
a symbolic gesture.
And so,
uh,
I leave it to you to question what that
gesture may be,
but,
but this community has been protected
under the existing grounds that are
found in most of the human rights codes
across,
uh,
across Canada and on the grounds of sex
here,
Senator Israel,
uh,
Mr Brown or Mr Peterson,
the,
uh,
Justice Wagner from the Supreme Court in
a seminar,
the Ottawa University,
uh,
in early March of this year,
which was a couple of months ago that
stated the following,
of course,
he was not giving a decision from the
bench you.
Nobody was expressing his views.
And if you allow me,
I will quote him.
It's short when the court eventually
faces a question touching on transgender
identity.
These to preposition will provide
essential frames of reference.
First one,
that identity is not fixed,
but changing as the first proposal.
And then the second one,
that identity is not innate but
contextual.
I'll repeat that the identity is not
innate,
but contextual or,
uh,
end of quote.
Um,
I,
I read that and I try to understand the
implication,
uh,
of this,
you know,
those two binary kinds of,
uh,
of,
elements of that and he says the court,
so I bet that he might have spoken to
colleagues or you know,
the profession generally
would you,
would you have a quarrel with that kind
of approach to the definition of
transgender a reality or a few things
that it's a proper way of approaching
legally the issues because as you
forcefully explain,
uh,
somebody,
one day my challenge,
uh,
you know,
the proposal,
the policies and all wet could stem from
the enactment of those legislations.
So in other words,
we'll find ourselves into court one day
and we will have to,
are,
you know,
to analyze and argue the case at least
taking into account that references
those references.
That just is wagner mentioned not long
ago.
So I'll you,
you will react to that.
Well,
I want to make sure I understand your
question properly.
So
when,
when the justice said this,
was he implying that the identity is not
fixed but it is changing and that
identity wasn't innate and it was
contextual or was he outlining the,
the,
the arena within which
this debate might take place?
No,
he was essentially,
it was,
you know,
there was another speech on this.
Essentially it was more if I can use an
expression that Mr Brown will
understand.
It was rather an arbitrary,
you know,
in a conference.
The conference was about identity.
But of course,
uh,
since uh,
you know,
identity is a topic of comment on common
debates in Canada.
He felt that,
uh,
it was fully,
if he would,
you know,
I should say,
put his grain of salt in the public
debate by establishing what he thinks
is,
you know,
out to define transgender identity and
establish some parameters.
Let's,
let's assume that it is changing and
contextual.
Okay.
Then why is conversion therapy a
problem?
See,
this is what I see.
The thing is is that when I started
opposing this bill,
people immediately assume that I was
transphobic and racist and all these
other epithets that they're perfectly
willing to try it forth at a moment's
notice,
but you know,
there's been a tremendous attempt to
make conversion therapy for people who
are gay,
illegal,
right?
And the proposition is predicated on the
idea that the identity,
the sexual preference,
identity is not changing nor contextual.
It's fundamental.
And really what that means is that it's
grounded in something like biology.
It's,
okay,
fine,
let's scrap that.
Okay,
now it's going to be changing and
contextual.
Okay,
then why can't it be changed with
context?
So this is part of the problem with the
policies.
Is there so incoherent that they're
going to work against the people that
they're designed to protect?
Now people have a hard time believing I
care about that,
but you know,
the fact that I've been called things
doesn't mean that that's what I am.
So you know a lot of people who have,
let's call it a nonstandard identity,
the tightest argument they have for
public acceptance of that identity is
that it's powerfully constrained by
biological processes that are beyond
their voluntary control.
So instantiate this view of humanity,
the social constructionist view of
humanity,
and you can waive those claims goodbye
because they are completely,
they are at complete odds with the
social constructionist view point and I
think that's a big mistake and I,
I really do believe that that will
backfire hard against the people who
this legislation is designed to protect.
If it's mutable,
changeable,
only subjective and transformable on a
whim,
then why should anyone have any respect
for it?
Gentleman,
they going to have to intervene.
The hour has flown by and we very much
appreciate your appearance here today
and your testimony as well.
Thank you.
We'll suspend briefly before hearing
from an expert.